all right you guys let's say so I'm just
going to get some streaming for now
let's just see if it works I know Eric
was having problems um so let's just
let's just see if I can get this going
so all right one second hold this chat
here okay you guys I don't know if
anybody's watching but I'm going to
start playing some games for just a bit
I think less you know that I'm I'm not
going to be going to this autograph
signing session shortly maybe in like 45
minutes into an hour or something so I'm
just going to try and play some games
quickly just give you guys some some
action before I have to go hang out with
people like spar van whatever stuff like
that um so yeah let's see so I'm going
to try and challenge Sergey he didn't
accept it let's see if Petro maybe or
nuki maybe I can play rlh - I've
actually played Rob with the other night
at the well-known trust house here in
st. Louis so we play quite a few games
late at night um so I don't know if you
guys we're following that or not I
thought someone just said nice
microphone yeah not normally at normal
I'm at home so I have it sitting on
sitting on my sitting on my desk but I'm
in st. Louis obviously so just holding
it right now so let's let's see if I can
get some games so all right challenge
the Gaul Kaimuki rlh - this angel our
rebus Christoph someone's gotta accept
right or not let's see hmm
hopefully I'm not waiting too long for a
game and on my intention
I said Bach who just said don't let this
fart get away with the touchmove like
the previous time yeah I I'm not going
to this term is a bit more serious he
does something like that this time while
he's not going to get away with it
anyway all right where is everyone
[Music]
hmm so yes I'm still waiting I sent out
five challenges I guess that's a max um
maybe or six ups a couple of games to
get guts and flow going so I'll just
play this ARMA narco and see what he
wants to do
I'll put c4 Knight c3 g6 g3 Bishop g2
since I'm actually not going to be
watching the stream if you guys just let
me on a chat there any issues with the
sound or stuff like that just feel free
to to let me know since I'm just trying
to play some games here
okay so h4 h5 night h3 maybe I'll put
the night on g5 maybe I'm not sure
possibly maybe I think for now to play
for e3 d4 and then maybe 95 d5 something
like this basics is a little bit weird
I've been trying to CC on keto but it's
not that either so I'll just play b3 try
to CC on keto to protect upon c4 so
let's just see what he wants to do here
okay castles alright since I feel like
having some fun I'll just I'll just try
to attack this is highly on sound
probably just doesn't work you probably
should just take it on g4 now he's going
to end up in some trouble because he's
losing a tribe so okay so it says I'm a
bit loud okay thanks for letting me know
I maybe that's time holding it too close
to me let me let me know if it's a
better now since I'm keeping the
microphone a little bit a little bit
further away from me
okay so h2 594
um okay so now I'm too quiet not better
okay just let me know where you guys
think it's best um as I said I'm not at
home obviously here in st. Louis so
Connie is hosting my stream okay
all right so 97 king b7 play h5 blocks
and troubles because I've also got this
diagonal here is some whoops I don't
want to prove up like that but about
this long diagonal here that I can take
full advantage of this Bishop b2
um so yeah so uh will you hold that the
whole stream yeah you think actually
that's what I'm gonna be doing I don't
have my stand with me
I'm literally with my right hand is
going to be like right here off the desk
and I'm just going to be like chillin
maybe not shilling maybe I try not to
play play over the board blitz like
against vivillon or running the other
guys later today if it's not keep one of
my hands right there on the side okay so
alright so game continues 295 to
discover check on the King on g7 here
I'll probably play night of 4 try 96 try
to get something with the King on f8
naturally so I'm threatening this this
double attack since the king is pen I'm
also attacking the knight on b7 here so
a lot of good stuff happening ok Queen
d600 bump up on I could take the knight
I'll try to make it more interesting on
51 obviously there's a free night
hanging on b7 but I'm not going to take
it so yeah sometimes so let's see so
someone's at Hanson sustained yeah
actually the other night there were a
bunch of us at the I don't know if it's
same now but there was a chess house
which is really close by to the Chess
Club and Scholastic Center here in st.
Louis and a bunch of over there playing
playing Blitzen bug house I was playing
against Aronian and Eric was there and I
beat him pretty bad we were playing 2
minutes straight up and scores 13 to 2
which I know maybe that's not not not
that it could have been for Eric but I
think he wanted more than that
so okay so this guy just hung there just
meet here one of seven so let's see okay
everyone's still idle most pop players
and see if I can get one of them to play
okay here we go someplace you Galka so
okay this guy's serious player Sam
earlier today so let's say it takes
takes some kind of some kind of on
Shyvana call Pelican pretty standard
stuff play six B 595 bish we sub takes
place C for force B for pretty
positional line when we go like g3 52h
for Bishop g2 all Cass will play
classical book reconsider pretty solid
for black so I'm just that so Eric's not
very good that's not that's not exactly
what I was saying he he actually he was
making a joke that I've never beaten him
10/10 over the board so so I've got to
get it up there one time so we'll see
when that's going to be that we play
next I think you're our Eric did go to
Spain he's playing some tournament there
on in the meantime okay h4 I'm going to
go teenage to Bishop age 3 try to force
an exchange with this LightSquared
bishop here on e6 so let's see so I
asked you I know who dr. Tancredi is I'm
not I'm not actually sir and I've heard
some rumors about a few different
players but as of the moment I'm not not
certain okay okay - so you want to do
something along this second rank I have
to be a little bit careful here maybe or
not I'll just take and play something a
little bit weird King h3 f3 get out of
anything here on the second rank his
Bishop balls on h6 is not perfectly
placed so there's a bit of a positional
struggle here my Knights not great his
bishops not so good he is we is very
weak pawn structure though d6 and B for
weaknesses and I don't really have
weaknesses but I can't really break
through at the moment so we'll see her
Cathedral play f3
don't hang up
- so not now I'm pretty solid or but
we're both kind of just solid here just
playing some moves
okay so g6 now I've got to figure out
how I'm going to proceed I can flick
Queenie - I can play okay one you've got
to think for good okay if I move the
rook I hang up - so I think I'll start
with rook e1 probably exchange with
rooks and then continue from there so
I'll take I'm going to bring something
around what's the best way to do this
work do you want clean up to Queen d6
looks pretty convincing I assume that I
have enough here with Queen e6 and so
forth so let's just let you see what
he's going to do someone just said is
this the real life
there are a lot of funny questions here
as you guys are saying why was your
beard not beneficial I don't think the
beard is the difference between playing
good shots and dad just it just wasn't
really my tournament unfortunately so
sometimes that happens I mean not a
whole lot you can do about it so all
right so King f7 bump on this is tricky
not so easy to play somehow so always
retreat back to e to avoid any cleanup -
nonsense
maybe I'll try for work d3 and Queen d1
movie that's a better setup possibly
again not easy to play for either side
here okay so now he's playing rugby - so
now he's going to give me the a file
potentially potentially if I want it um
III lost Queen G 1 or K 1 work b3 there
could be some slight issues here let's
just see so Queen d3 also Queen d3 is
this might be bad I might have just
allowed Queen up - but maybe not so he
doesn't want it so I'm way down on the
clock so I'm going to I'm going to do
something suicide I don't play off for
f5 next time just to try and create
something and knock it flagged so we'll
see what happens
so okay so my Kings a little bit open
now but it's still relatively safe she
has no entry squares off to it's covered
for example the night here cuts off the
rook on the second rank
so we'll see what he wants to do so
Bishop g7 I'm just going to I'm just
going to go all and I don't really care
okay so Bishop e5 he doesn't have a
threat though so he doesn't have an
actual threat or he does oh I missed
that one
oops oops oops oops and if I go you know
all right just as rook c3 that's not
going to work yeah that was way to our
yeah whatever that's not going to work
it's completely overlooked up but maybe
I'd work f7 or something that's not
really paying enough attention to long
time also but I'm alright are actually
five seriously okay we're cus eight okay
so I'm just going to play Traxler knight
of sevens supposed to be the winning
line this I feel like this is probably
all supposed to good for white but I
haven't honestly really ever looked this
line from the black side so it's all
today I'll play Knight g4 try to do
something here on III 2d wants to do so
what's this nice shirt yeah it's a shirt
I got after after a REMS half marathon
in Seattle a couple weeks back so yeah
nice curtains well yeah I'm at this
hotel engineers at Lois so I you know
you might want to come stay at this
hotel sometime if but if you wanna have
the same curtains okay so Knight c3 so I
can take I can play Knight F to Queen h5
doesn't look so hot I'm writing I'll
just take on e38 h6 to possibly but 95
bothered me a little bit so probably
play Knight d5 I assume but he might not
I mean we'll so we'll see what he wants
to do
so I'll see what you want to do again
you guys are there any issues with the
streams laggy or anything going on just
let me know so okay so Bishop d5 now h6
Queen h5 i soon as i this idea you just
wants to clean inch five and something
queen h5 queenie a probably is what it
will happen um he goes go Knight f3 of
course as well I think queen h5 takes is
probably just to draw so oh he doesn't
want to okay or did I just hang
something I might have just made a
blunder in that if Bishop c6 I can't
take back then hopefully 95 Knight take
C so it's like a fork or something
something nasty maybe maybe it's not so
good I can just go King d7 um so let's
just see what he wants to do now okay so
it takes on c6 I can take on f3 I mean
it's very even unfortunately I'll try it
trap and I'll try to give them the fake
Shrek with 95 knight c6 here ok doesn't
want any part of it so I'll just let
Queen b8 try to go Queen b6 and double
the works on the F file
let's check I woke up six I mean I still
Queen e1 work out brick a Fe it looks
pretty pretty draw but okay if you want
to go Queen e2 now I can go work update
and he's got some weaknesses here on f3
so okay so some of those the
backlighting is bad let me just uh let's
do what I can do to improve that after
this game just give me a second conflict
2005 basically take advantage of this
week pawn structure here if I can I
think I'll run I'm going to try and
bring my King around to the other side
just get it safe here over here I can
okay h4 upload this v8 now I can't
really move as night because I'm c2 is
going to hang so I'm just going to keep
bring my king all the way over okay
Knight h4 plate g6 just cut off the
night
so it's insisting on exchanging a bunch
of pieces unfortunately now let's see
please see five complete c4 to be really
interesting those the King's King here
and then okay Queen d2 varied rosh
varied rosh okay King a5 probably he'll
go c3 maybe maybe he won't not actually
sure I just well close my blinds going
on sighs eyes see if this is better
yeah whatever maybe it's better maybe
it's not all also you guys say um now
for the brilliant to the center I'm
going to sack see if this works or not
probably it doesn't work probably is
noisy 493 making a draw it kind of kind
of realm I'll make the print let's just
see what he wants to do okay so it's
trying to create something here of this
so take their eyes and also it can be
type probably just take and I'll take
and play a king before let's see what
his idea is now
play a 5 try to go for king state 3 this
might still be something can be through
take take C 5 H - a - I mean I complete
King B 3 make a draw and then how much
more I can do really to make a draw here
but also
maybe I can slack once you see what he
is going to do okay
oh he just hung his Queen I didn't see
it that's terrible
it was just awful so I'm just going to
flacon or something oh my god I'm just
playing bad shots right now let me see
like six curtains okay so I can do
okay okay I don't know is this better or
not let's see okay someone said it's
better okay now I can focus let's see
what he's going to do um take I'll just
take probably lady for probably d6 maybe
I just want to plea for okay so let's
take place it for ya bit of pomp in a
knight on c3 okay let's say okay Bishop
g4 I'll put Queen c2 okay okay you can
play Queen off five probably castle and
Queen off three knocks move let me just
see okay I don't know if I can do much
better than that for now you guys but
it's going to have to have to do for now
so
anyway
therapy one
darkness is upon us okay um sorry you
guys like I said before I'm not at home
here and say it Lois let me just try to
turn on some light
this better maybe now there's some more
light okay
click ft one
[Music]
okay let's see so 94 oh I wanted a 93
timeless played this slightly at all
I'll make do I think it's really drippy
five swing that creates an activity for
the book possibly like 94 work b-side
for example okay let's see I'm going to
do okay on 20 seconds not the end of the
world not yet at least
what's you up to yeah I'm just here
doing this a little bit I think in like
15 minutes or some autographs learn that
we also do as players after the rapid
blitz so I'll be heading over there at
some point
okay Queen g6 clear-cut 5 and basically
once exchange it's nice here on e4 and
come to get this you know you've got
these Queen side pawns here and he wants
to kind of roll them down the board so
my plan is not to let them do that so a
six looks like a bad no I think that D
slides here
when you southern all the I'll grab it
sits bragging to be played so I've got
to do it queen cheese for play the fee
seven maybe we'll have to go with these
seven and all the d6 and his rook is a
lot worse than a bishop
or maybe he'll just take or is rip to
five shoot I'm not seeing stuff to add
that's three maybe three or H three
issues and maybe if you clean it five
chief for I like H three maybe I'm blind
me to just lose this for something but I
like it
th5 so now do a cake yeah i think i
capably before I think I just take I'll
probably take the night I assume maybe
not
I assumed you would so I'll play a four
still not find situations not great here
but okay so 25 I will take play this bus
693 over p1 probably would be swifty
eight eyes got this I gotta be fast now
gotta move really fast now so I play
with a zucchini three
see - I'll play with each one not ideal
but still again okay Cheers
b3 Rekha fate stop b8 here B six cups
all to g5 what am i doing let's see
still up on the clock here fortunately
but let's see like a day I'll probably
see - maybe not the time to play that's
why don't ya there we go much better
much better
ok one up such one
to 396 now the Advanta lured game just
say what to do now the thule 6 CL
console should be 3/8 perky one probably
should be 6 so we're playing this exact
line earlier today so this isn't this is
an exactly groundbreaking theory
alright so flagging is greater than
shots
yes I wholly approve us vlogging is
awesome but Baku's I think it was um
let's see okay so who who said that that
wasn't the clue Sarge got distracted by
the chat um okay so so far pretty
standard night's f33 cheese exotics
alright so then I'd see four I'll play
rookie DHS no no no no nonsense here on
b6 now what now I've got to start
thinking about how to attack so I'll
play Knight of four attack upon her Rd
here maybe I'll go 90 to five maybe not
not sure yet
96 I'll play Queen c7 I want to use
something on this diagonal potentially
long run also now after d5 the Queen
protects the pawn here on e5 so g3 you
can take on e4 we can not take on e4 and
clean 96 Oakland 86 just keep it simple
everything is defined it protected King
g2 or 56 probably going to double on the
D file if I get the chance
tonight on beat sixes also it's well
placed but it's not really doing a whole
lot in a bigger scheme of thing so it's
not ideal it's on someone's asking me
wait Kris Kris wings cut exactly if I
could find a bigger microphone sorry I
think this is big as it comments
horizont no sorry that's not that came
out wrong
all right okay time for hopefully work
t8 if you take I'll take up a night I
can't hear you like running her out
sorry that's not a request that I cannot
that I can do okay now you five now here
I should have night a fourth things
maybe you mean whites okay I don't know
it's weird but maybe staking up three
okay this King's kind of open so I can
play work e6 here I can take into a wiki
eight also I can take d3 so what's the
way to finish this off this soon it
seems so easy on all this ball I guess
I'll play work out six protect upon top
seven this King is very open they're
going to be all kinds of discoveries now
on the king so yeah so someone's acting
again did I get to beat up Eric yeah
actually I think there are a couple
people to chat who were actually
watching when I played Eric at the Chazz
house a few nights ago so rookie four so
I can play Knight g6 pick up the knight
93 93 looks like the right move
but King e3 and some probably seems like
he's kind of holding but I don't care I
don't care about the raid and I'm just
going to try to play good attack and
Chuck's um so I'll take the three
probably hold Oh King e2 not King III
interesting so now I can play work F 2 T
3 this is very weird
maybe I just I'll go back to my original
plan or play Knight c5 and just pick up
the rook on e4 I'm also way down on time
so I'm gonna have to ignore the chat for
a few minutes probably in order to try
and cooperate all this time that I lost
so it's always going to do probably take
takes Queen for the Queen seven at the
end of that or something or disrupt be
six maybe take the open file that
probably makes more sons just to get
this right here on the Open File
probably put in I don't see for as many
gaps maybe not we'll see
but I've caught up on time which is good
come play with you six you know five
I'll play with these seven protect the
pawn and I'll keep my queen free to come
into the game and a few moves so let's
see who's the King probably Queen d5 can
I find it I'll check I'll check on on
these five I'll probably turn another
Chuck just to be annoying or not he's
going to go to e3 fine I'll play Queen
d1 I'll just try to make me some extra
time what is this Queens you for come on
seriously Clinton without a sled
seriously
Queen g4x mmm Queen on five okay time
time to focus for a few games now all be
ignoring the chops and that's like five
minutes or something so we can do here
sonnet there should be three councils
III probably okay let's take and play d3
[Music]
okay let's see yeah probably just a
little bit too little bit too slow if I
was up like 30 seconds I mean probably
be slightly different but doesn't much
matter what time I went to blunder that
but I've been trying to talk to talk to
you guys during the game so okay let's
see um what's your advice for him on
Hamilton to get his file she don't I
don't know actually um you know it's
weird I knew him all and he was firstly
getting good when he's like twenty one
twenty two hundred and um he's improved
a lot since then I feel like he's been
someone the 2400 range for like maybe I
don't know maybe like a year now or
something I don't know where he's been
exactly but it was a very good player
probably it's just uh he needs to play
more I think I feel like I didn't see
them playing everywhere but like when
you're trying to get you know more
titles generally it's a generally uh you
know important to play as much as you
can
it's 98 I'll play with def 196 I don't
know I don't know what I'll do maybe
just Knight up seven or something
as soon as he's played Bishop e6 play
work f6
I'll take late age three cut off the
night know g4 Square and now he goes in
I said I have 97 if you plays work see
it I can play work out boys Clinton's
lives long he's kind of getting shocked
mated here this night is really bad Roni
h6 splits be sick so I play g4 there are
a lot of attractive options everything
I'm just going to play something sound a
practical King h2 now open a g5 Kings
you southern I'll play with d6 of course
or not or just entry 3 yeah probably
seems u7 just gotten g3 905 though so
key 7 now I'll play entry 3
let me try to bring my king closer here
let's say so now I'll put th for
probably King g7 I don't play with c6
to avoid any night of five tricks coming
tonight g8 I will just grab or not see I
think just grab it 6 9 f3 probably I'm
just like g4 maybe not a good move
actually committee probably b5 it's
really really unpleasant and I'll play
for and take away this b5 stuff and I'll
probably just lick him 2 3 next move my
king out of danger and I think now he's
actually seeing that he had b5 it's 98
and I will not retreat my king I assume
I'll play I don't what to do fine oh
I'll just play King g3
I'll give him 96 Rick before and this
isn't really what I wanted but it could
be worse it's a 5 so take 9422 probably
Knight c3 Knight each for work see 795
it's looking fairly good really good for
the moment on this game I'm way up on
time which is important to the g5 so
we'll see one I completely actually like
rook c6 just protect upon turn on c3 is
no rule like entry squares 7 I'll play
rook e1 probably work update and maybe I
can play rook III or I can just take the
knife he's got no time so I'm just I'm
just going to take and go rookie 2
[Music]
if you had more time I would be a little
bit more concerned but he doesn't so oh
just keep on chugging away work c5 now
I'm trying to take e4 yeah I know I'll
just take 85 take a five just up up a
couple pawns here Chuck
B 6 a 5
ok so you want to do I mean this is of
course a draw just to be clear but but
or maybe it's not actually you put the
King here I'm not sure and he blundered
sure enough okay so II for I'll just
keep playing same stuff sling boron
Berlin to upset everyone saying let your
chat hopefully there won't be curtains
wait Lausanne hopefully there won't be
curtains Oh
at the tournament yeah I don't think
there will be I mean I can I can also
open it I'm not sure what the best thing
is what you guys think is better
[Music]
I'll ask that I 2 3 I'll play I'll play
the old one can you eat who is who an
amateur player adapt name is a golf go
it's an amateur player on my the amateur
player I don't know someone's an amateur
player so far in the smash it's probably
me anyway let's see
the three alpha Bishop e6 d1 salt pretty
pretty well known pretty even probably
they'll take oral takes here this is a
little bit less calm and I think I'll
play I'll say something unusual please
see five and ninety four it's not a
common plant only politically v b6 a5 I
just want to stop some ninety five here
so I don't know if this is necessarily
the best way of playing but it looks
interesting enough he5 play dish of c8
or Bishop d7 finding things I don't
really like there should be seven I'm
just going to go 94 keep it really
simple so the cake I just take 94 I mean
or takes Keeney six also as possible
probably I think I should take back at
the night I think but we'll see we'll
see what he does I mean I can take back
with the pawn 94 I mean it's it's pretty
92 night night there be 696 c5 may be
hard to play but it actually makes them
sons
let's just see what we want to do first
so he does 94 assault takes I want to
take on c5 and upload b6
so he does go for it so you take so I
don't place v5 and try to drop this
night here on a six if I get the chance
I mean I could be miss calculating
something here but oh it looks pretty
good so far at least so let's just see
what's his ox idea I mean you could try
a four maybe
again he seems to be fairly slow here so
I'm doing pretty well um anyway so
alright so let's see what's next is
going to be he's using a lot of time
here I have to say so he's clearly
thinks he's he hasn't played the right
way so I can play 94 I can play with
these sudden maybe rupee 785 okay that
looks that looks interesting or just
work now I mean I don't want to waste
all my time so I go 94 try try to remain
somewhat practical and I'll plus c4
although actually somehow not as much
time as I thought I was and maybe
there's some kind of lag or something I
thought I was up like like 30 35 seconds
somehow not but anyway so exceed three
can play b5 I can also I think I'm going
to play something with h4 here try and
try and loosen these pawns loose in the
structure that I maybe have an e to F
for possibility later because it plays
work do you wanna play with d8 you can
take if he wants 1992 is really strong
in fact 92 here might be extremely
strong I'm just going to take first so
case with the rook interest so now I've
C 3 C 2 and what is he doing exactly
searching selling King f8 and I think I
might just be winning here possibly yeah
I think you might have just missed c3
maybe he thought I only like Knight a5
or something and you'll see two flicks
II want to play Knight 92 that's the key
very important okay so he takes it
clearly he did blunder now Fuxi trg7
looks kind of wrong don't really like 90
to 92 might only be a draw so this'll
take it like this probably play with
chief or the knight c6 I'm sure he knows
this 96 move rook e1 now get the Knight
to f5 and that's why this whole age 42
threw some pork snow it's what
king-sized structure is just a big mess
because now it's like they're almost are
no squares even saw were key to maybe
that's a bad move actually but Oh
doesn't matter
oh whoa I got to be careful oh I've got
this shot done
yeah okay I should get and now I should
just clean up the ponds okay she's going
to make some some questionable so-called
attempts guys geez this guy is really
tricky guys really tricky always plays
these moves when he goes how much time
just to like one take blunder a piece
I'm going to be falling for it today um
okay so say for play just standard
traffic gun you should be some Bishop d3
but it can keep asking questions if you
feel like it on Castle
d sighs assault this pretty normal on
Bishop d2 Bishop d6 I'll play 92 93
probably he'll play off 5 I soon let's
see one Queen c2 little all pretty
standard although actually played 97
first so I think you might have a lot of
Bishop b5 now let's see what's he going
to do Queen e7 so hopefully Bishop c6
try to force the bishops off the board
and this way is pawn here is backwards
on c7 g6 flip Queen b3 attack upon here
on f6 Knight there I can take and play
95 maybe looks weird I'm just going to
play a three I want to play Bishop b4 if
I get the chance now we're playing a 5
the pawn pawn can never go back so so
you might have weakened their structure
I'm not not saying to kill killer blow
here so I'm just going to play with c1
keep putting pressure on them probably
one drop drop it back maybe play Knight
e5 and / - maybe not I think I'll play
Queen c2 though I like I like the I like
the position that I
out here probably he'll take on g3
Edison but I'm not sure so please f4
interesting so now I think here I'm
going to take always 94 which I just
completely forgot about for signing them
double question mark so before try to
open this up probably Fe Fe I expected
to take
so now g5 I can play 95 I guess 95 takes
or just this is not really how it's
supposed to play this but all I have to
make do it's what I have so play 95 I'll
take take probably I'll play Queen b3
I'm guessing just try and hope that
somehow I can survive this I mean his
queen side is weak so even though black
spider they're in a classical game or
still are what I would say are pretty
good drawing chances for Hawaii
so take stakes
and he's Steven the thing he can
attained it so let's see let's see how
it's here it's 94 is a good move I don't
really want to do that maybe different
g3 or I think I'll just play with d1
tact upon here on d5
so rips s8
Bishop g3 takes takes takes takes I'll
go for it I don't really see anything
better so probably takes a prime just
all the state d5 will take you three
I'll go King H 2 and this is some kind
of were component it's going to turn in
some kind of workup on and again
I don't know if I'm actually losing this
or not I mean those dot a Dodge is that
all work employment games are drawn I
don't know if this one is or not I mean
I am down to pawns but black is passive
at the same time so it's not as bad as
it could be so we'll play b5 now don't
actually know what I'm doing here I'm
just kind of like wandering aimlessly
chunk 55 probably it works c4 I'm also
down clock which doesn't help okie size
so he's going to do here I'm kind of
just lost onboard so I just have base
left it's like really really fast okay
yeah let's let's see if I can somehow
make make this work probably I can't but
it's mmm you're not so easy
OHP just as a 5x7 yeah very good okay so
let's do we want to do apply a six play
something different against this guy I
mean I can play e5 every game but
getting a little bit tired if this plane
is boring JUCO pianos so let's just see
something else
take this would be for C 327
I'm h3 employee 696 pretty standard
stuff nothing too exciting d5 at 95
probably hold this carefully I'll play
what will I play all this with Bishop e7
probably at some point we have our night
before in 95 but for now I was Castle
although the other 83 here which could
be a slight issue but we'll see what he
wants to do okay so he does play a three
so Peter Brooks eh probably Bishop 82 90
95 I'm just going to go right for the
c-4 square of D 5 94 is my plan
so let's see well it will probably take
I guess the eggs can be seven again this
is not not been a good session it's
hopefully queen c6 try to force try to
force off some pieces here I also maybe
could have played b5 maybe and given up
a queen in early scene very attractive
so I'm just going to plan on game
because his nose still alright you guys
I think probably up like three more than
I have to go to this autograph thing
here so there should be 492 working 791
looks good if you please repeat one -
day 3 looks good
biggest blunder B - maybe maybe he did
I'll say what a noob said I don't knock
it ever reach chat um I do I do read it
from time to time it actually depends I
mean how would the players in our
clients are pretty good like this guy
the Galka that I'm playing that on it's
pretty rare I kind I can't really you
know lose like 30 seconds on the clock
John only but if I'm playing something a
little bit a little bit slower a little
bit weaker than the gentleman I can just
read I mean like everything but
sometimes the time does matter I mean
depending how how strong a players it's
93 I'll just play rookie 3 try attacked
upon her on a 3 a 4 33 between 84 I like
this movie taxes oh I just let 9200 man
Wow
not good we said night see size up that
works but it's not really it was really
not what I was planning to do so Brooke
c7 hope it works III I think probably 67
me just 94 problems knife or makes more
sense
oh you just want to play that game on
time so a 5 so I'll play with da try to
go work D 1 or K 1 or K 5 I'll play 52
if 94 works before work before and
that's game stakes oh good good let's
see it is all I'll get I'll try now to
play something a bit more standard
kaolinite 2 3 should be 5
and I eat five I guess castle this is
some ancient Anan theory maybe I'm crazy
it takes and Bishop d3 or am I just
insane I could just be insane um one I
feel like this is some kind of weird
theory from ages ago
d3 d66 b3 I can't remember it so I'm
just going to have to just play random
moves okay so he's saying that this is
just a draw I mean no I don't want to
draw I want to play let's see so II 6 so
the bishop c2 again we should be three
again let's see if he's going to retreat
and I just want to draw really
interesting quickly h5 maybe but now
it's bishop fiancée want to so under
develop and I just like and but not
exactly very exciting on let's see I'll
play see fine play French maybe let's
see we want to do I want to plan advance
okay
96 Queen b6 III all right it's it's
probably be four should be seven all not
horribly exciting but still this just um
right 94 is not new so playoff six
take stakes 9356 onigiri will approve of
the draw if it takes probably 94 I would
assume but 27
okay so bg5 I'll just castle
ofE tEEX or if you please Rick you want
I think I might be able to 94 so you
just take key one on probably plays and
then foreign fish bus seven use this
Beach five a litter point with d5 isn't
hanging um let's just say okay so now
for I'll play click Queen da just give
95 doesn't much matter and soon he's
going to do here I'll play p6
I'll just see okay so we're seeing I'm
probably just like F Forbush page five
it's pretty pretty boring though
unfortunately so so I can eke or not
I'll take it's probably not the right
move objectively but um I feel like
trying to create some action so just sit
d5 and play hopefully work see to
probably up for next move or III simply
D for mating D Forex III enough for c4
would be one yeah why not let's just see
it now if you can also click weaned
before and that's slightly wrong oh that
was not good okay so Ricky to now let's
look at what's the wrong and give me one
second okay security sick so just feel
like bit of g6 again so work up to we're
just Bishop g6 just plain almost 97 King
King f8 take Stacy 78 looks fine now
that wasn't room tour it's probably
something telling me that I should go to
the club at some point soon for the
signing or something I don't even know
exactly what but okay so we're to 6e
seven probably worked e 7f for I can
he'll go fish we eat for maybe
five maybe just like rooks III or
something I don't our came out fate yeah
maybe just can take stock see when I can
take and play tricky to refer KD one I
can still play with you six I think
probably take takes 94 takes this could
be bad
could be an hour for two different
things though I mean maybe at the east
seven this could be a problem with Izzy
southern here but he didn't play you
play Brooke great do you want but even
oh but actually I can just take and you
just take and take up five and it's just
even okay so I mean this picture just be
a draw but we shall see how he wants to
post seed
and I can also maybe try to roll my king
to g4 h 3i what do you guys say okay all
go for it I'll try to roll my can
probably go play NIDA oh is not going to
play Knight up to is going to actually
try so this is going to get interesting
because now he's going to win my queen
side pawns I'm going to win his King
side pawns probably so all-in-all it
la-la-la probably can you three tastes
enough for h6 go gotta go with the pawns
now 96 55
well let's just see how do okay so he's
trying to do something here at the
Rockies
so yeah me there's not much I can
actually do it or maybe just assembly it
wrong
unfortunate how very sad
yeah there's not much I really can do
here so I'll try something yeah it's
just draw or is it or did I just blunder
it all away yeah it's not yeah what am I
crazy maybe still it's still probably
draw anyway but only kind of stupid Oh
more not her nose small girl yeah that's
ridiculous just dead wrong but whatever
not stupid that was ridiculous um yeah
judge wrong okay it's really stupid
all right last two now it's just
ridiculous
all right so let's submission t-33
hopefully chief or try to create some
some kind of King side attack maybe
something along these lines
92-93 probably simply c5 no just play
something we're probably um I'm good g5
here I guess g5 97 95 maybe let's just
see I don't I don't know if this is good
but I have 40 f 497 I'll just take or
not um food helper before I want to take
away from the center of the post towards
the center um I'm not sure if that's
going to happen so let's say say please
see for Bishop c2
is there no sound or something sorry
there is a really no sound
is there something missing is my sound
is my sound good or not is there
something wrong someone just let me know
oh my sound is good okay okay sorry
someone just said there was no sound so
I just kind of want crazy well can I
just ate and again I've got myself into
a pretty bad position but once you'll
see so f5 he'll surely tank I'll play
Queen G to Queen h4 f3
I'll take probably rookie 2 or C 2
rookie to work F to take stakes yeah g6
um what to do what to do I don't really
want to take but I will play off six
okay so it's using time here which is to
my advantage if I am a little bit worse
so what you want to do so okay so please
pick off five interesting fish about
four Bishop e5 try to create some
counterplay ninety-six Bishop e5 I can
click eg three also maybe work h1 here
or something
it is Bishop e5 of four hopefully I'll
play for me I'll play work h1 and try to
try to double my Brooks up here if I can
it's not gonna be easy but just see what
I can do
maybe this would be five or something a
tricky one now and now I'll play Ricky
one plucky two over cage to is no good
right
so I'll just play Bishop t6o is Ritchie
- jeez yikes yikes yikes yikes that's
not good
I completely overlooked with you - but
play so I please see three now here we
work H to maybe do I've any other moves
like F for maybe for Ricky - or - to
King three takes off for maybe um yeah
it's pretty bad um I'll just tape on
play work see one playoff for next move
after c2
I mean it's got to please see - I would
think um but let's see okay let me go
King III King okay complete King off
three
see if I can somehow create some tricks
here
play our I just on each sex act it's not
going to get it done perché five maybe
I'm going to have to be really fast or
just bad
so it was going to do work
what am i doing what am i doing I just
like blender this hall way like yeah
yeah it's just not going to get it done
Oh yikes yeah I mean I was completely
fine and I just like blundered blundered
the pawn for no reason very careless you
know that's not good
so 92 g5 complain a chief for allegedly
96 and castles probably Knight f6 next
move depending what he does
someone says I'm losing some not playing
the bonk
yeah that's that's not actually the
reason I'm losing was I'm just playing
badly so what did I just again what am i
what am i doing what am i doing just
yeah plant playing a lot of bad was
right now okay so take takes 95 Bishop
d5 so f4f six probably or f4 night h4
maybe after we have six maybe queen d3 I
play f5 I think I like Queen up I think
I like Queen off six videos or I think
I'll just play off five of it now you
see four so actually this double is
there are two reasons he did it wasn't
actually to play to play what I thought
you wanted plays just to play c4 um yeah
this is pretty terrible 96 Queen h4 hope
for something Knight f8 there's no night
f8 rook F theta I guess yeah not not not
attractive to say the least um okay so d
f g5 f for no um g8 is probably bad to
you Polly 95 me here maybe 95 slate for
us for maybe but again I just completely
allowed now I'll add him to play off for
so yeah not not very good just play on
yeah what will I do here clean off
citrus allows about four hours terrible
Oh bump bump bump ah let's just sit
cream 85 of 48 by some check maybe
probably not work g2 takes 48 I don't
know if that makes any sense but
you can also probably just play work f2
as well but kaity and Chuck and check
and no he is 95 yeah it doesn't even
work out that yeah really bad okay one
last one that's it just play something
simple
okay let's see for probably two 6-pin
hd3 it's got to be fast in this game
I've done only been much too slow
oh come on I'm going to play off three
obviously yeah
swim last one yeah one last game that's
it that was really just bad okay Bishop
e7 Bishop F one out of five minus three
castles just D 5 D for Bishop e3 Bishop
d6 like g6 9 f 1h s7 or c6 pretty draw a
line not not terribly exciting 93 97
probably just f6 Bishop c4 rook e8 now
let's play Queen c7 and probably Bishop
g4 next move um ooh
c4 ooh progressive very aggressive so
Knight f5 905 Bishop f5 looks climb
mystery some takes takes takes yeah this
looks ok so wait what does this look ok
I don't know this doesn't yeah
wait what is this I just wandering
exchange
huh wow that was terrible
okay yeah clearly I'm not seeing
anything okay so this is going to be
lost game regardless maybe I can do
something and it's pretty pretty
terrible but I can maybe hope for
something 96 rookie 7 real got7 rookie 1
king of fate
Alpha Team si takes takes this is maybe
not totally lost maybe probably it's bad
but maybe not completely lost
put a knight on e4 put it right back on
d6 right back on e4 put it right back on
d6
maybe I mean is this is obviously quite
terrible for block but play h6 maybe g5
I think I'll play g5 now for a six so
let's see so okay so I'm definitely
picking up seven fish base five c1
Bishop d6 now start to bring my knight
to the game one way or the other
93 yeah not not not good for maybe I can
get some no I can't run too slow close
work c3 I am
yeah it's clearly just too much too much
too much
yeah I'm just cakes and really not yeah
it's just too much trying to play like
this so yeah so clearly you guys I'm
going to need to get a better better
setup better setup for next time when
I'm not actually at home because clearly
it's affecting my play a little bit the
size is playing badly so yeah alright
you guys I think that's going to be it
for now and I will maybe come back later
if I can find a better side up maybe a
little bit better better chair better
posture better um yeah just obviously
need to set this microphone down
somewhere too so yeah alright guys so I
think that's going to be at Wow and I
will come back maybe later maybe not
just have to figure it all out so anyway
I hope you guys enjoy to unit was
terrible but um I'll be back at some
point in the near future so have a good
afternoon everyone maybe I'll see
something at the club if not until next
time